My God guys
[music]
no more
guys no more
What to do Lord had mercy on Odessa citizens
Come save the extinguishment of the cathedral
What to do Where to run It’s all possible everything
falls on your head all the cathedral no more
happened landing at the right limit of the altar of the
main Holy place of the cathedral Oskol
flew over  through the entire cathedral and ended up instead of
selling icons of candles of literature and there There
was a fire everything else everything
else did not burn only one
corner was on fire which was extinguished there these icons are
new
building this is of no value
[music]
super high attacking Thieves
Maybe they will attack on
such a day  tactics song obedient night
attack was attacked the
region's infrastructure facilities be it a weasel
Be you must dust
Well we already cried for them already and Someone told him a
very
military descent
four houses private private sector